chances de bonheur arrive donc à la fin
de la visite d'eric zemmour à marseille
il est dans sa voiture il s'apprête à
regagner la gare et une dame est bien le
demande à lui parler il baisse sa
fenêtre cette dame lui fait un doigt
d'honneur en lui disant aux casses toi
et eric zemmour lui répond par un autre
doigt d'honneur
etc ce moment pensé alors lui il va dire
c'est inadmissible et va pas du tout non
jules verne 12 aurais je vais vous
expliquer je me suis dit pour analyser
il faut pas tenir compte du fait que ce
soit eric zemmour l'auriez fait vous
exactement les mêmes faits ce week-end
non ben oui c'est ça mais je le sais pas
ça parce que les opposants à vous
allez voir des
voix lorsque tu as les yeux sur ce
nombre à 10 h au dôme
bah ouais c'est les vélos qui respectent
pas les feux rouges blancs je me
précipite comme ça et je fais je le fais
pas là mais je fais un doigt il me fait
un doigt c'est la même scène non et oui
il a de la chance de pas s'être arrêté
le gars franchement qu'est ouais voilà
donc honnêtement pour moi c'est de
l'impulsivité c'est pas bien mais c'est
pas plus donc ça me hérisse écrit ça se
tape pas les civils exactement ça ne
méritaient pas toutes les critiques pour
moi on a beaucoup critiqué parce que c
est mort et c'est pas normal voilà
justement moi je pense pas que ce soit
de l'impulsivité je pense que c'était
attendu c'était voulu c'est quelque
chose qu'il a voulu montrer c'est
quelque chose qu'il a cherché et au
final belge ans qu'il est content que
copier cette image qui sortent et il
l'assumé totalement non mais moi je
pense sincèrement que si parce que tu
fais pas un truc si oui tu as peur que
ça ça retient sur ille à wigan non mais
moi je pense que x men il l'a fait de
façon impulsive s'était pas réfléchi
autres mais en revanche ça le gêne pas
plus que ça parce qu'il est sur une île
trump heist et trump il a été aussi élu
pour ça le potez distribuer six
aujourd'hui comme un oui parce que bien
sûr mais quand même trump aussi c'est
alors moi je pense qu'il aurait pas dû
s'excuser oui on dira jamais jamais
lassé me faire aller pour faire croire
que c'était pas ouais mais mais mais
c'est une connerie à mon avis voilà si
vous tapez une connerie et tu fermes ta
gueule et tu as fait voilà j'ai un peu
du mal à vous dire parce qu'il était mon
tout nous tomber dessus en plein débat
sur reste que du coup il a la stature
d'un président de ça pour l'instant il
n'est pas président il n'est même pas
candidat pour l'instant c'est un citoyen
quelqu'un vient vers lui histoire il est
juste quantité dans saab à
la maison du parc qui va t'amener un mot
carton et bien pour l'instant voilà
qu'est une femme vient vers lui lui
manque du respect ni lui répond avec le
même respect point barre moins 50% pour
dolan
d'accord chirac souvenez-vous de chirac
sont pointés l'établissement
zemmour sa stratégie stratégie l
éclairage et mons et de rompre avec tout
ce qui s'est fait en politique jusqu'ici
donc ceux qui disent qui désacralise la
fonction de candidats ou de potentiel
président oui mais il le fait exprès ça
c'est un geste qui l'a dit que tout le
monde fait en étant un peu familier il
se met au niveau de tout le monde et il
crée pas de fossé entre les gens et les
politiques comme ça c'est que l'espace
excuses et guillaume moi je crois qu'il
n'y a pas réfléchi il fallait à
s'excuser alors non mais vraiment
rationnement des puits quoi un homme
politique ne réfléchit pas dans ses
actes mais la salle est spontané alors
moi je dis oui c'est une réaction
exactement ce à quoi s'est spontanément
franchement c'est un doigté franche toi
c'est normal
dira au match je
[Rires]
me rends toi j'en fais un mail au point
d'échouer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]